This video is brought to you by keeps.
What's up. Wisecrack Michael here. I don't know if you knew this,
but a lot of people are having totally level-headed reasoned debates about
censorship these days.
We are,
we are living under Linda living for that effect under communist regime.
Right now we're living under a Nazi regime, a communist regime,
a fascist regime.
Just kidding. YouTube removes videos for spreading medical misinformation,
tic TAC, shadow ban certain political content.
University professors are losing their jobs. And it seems like every week,
Facebook and Reddit are banning entire communities that violate their terms of
service.
As for the government civil rights lawyers accused the us military of violating
the first amendment for banning users on their Twitch streams who asked them
about war crimes. And then, you know, there's this.
[Inaudible].
A lot of it raises a central question. What is censorship?
Am I being unjustly censored?
When I get thrown out of my local taco bell after smearing myself and mashed
potatoes to protest their anti Spud menu changes.
What about if I do it at city hall more seriously,
we might ask about what it means when private entities who have always had a
right to refuse people service for many, but not all reasons.
Get the fact check a public figure or black people from sharing a news article
about this son of a presidential candidate Americans like to celebrate our long
history free expression. And as a result,
we really hate when something looks or even just feels like censorship,
but it turns out the way we think about censorship is often wrong and usually
inadequate for thinking about what it looks like today to figure out what is
happening. Let's go back to the beginning in this wisecrack addition on,
and before we get into it, I want to give a shout out to keeps.
It can be really embarrassing to talk about getting older.
It seems like your back is always out of lack.
You don't recognize all the memes on Twitter and some people might find
themselves losing their hair. In fact,
two out of three guys will experience some form of male pattern baldness by the
time they're 35, unfortunately you can't just urban dictionary away.
The solution to losing your hair.
However you can turn to keeps keeps is an affordable hair loss treatment program
that provides FDA approved prescription and over-the-counter medication.
You used to have to go to the doctor's office for hair loss prescription,
but thanks to keeps you can visit a doctor online and get the medication
delivered right to your home.
They make it easy and deliver your medication every three months.
So you don't have to make any extra trips to the pharmacy.
Keeps treatments can take four to six months or more to see results.
So the sooner you act, the more hair you can save,
find out why keeps has more five-star reviews than any of its competitors.
And why hundreds of thousands of men trust keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication go to keeps.com/wisecrack or click the link in the description to
receive 50% off your first order. Now back to the show,
it'd be hugely disappointing to our philosophically inclined fans.
If I didn't mention one of ancient histories,
most notable victims of censorship and 99 BC,
a 70 year old man in Athens was sentenced to death on two charges,
corrupting the youth and worshiping false gods.
The man was Socrates and he was critical of the young democratic government of
Athens, which was at war with its neighbors. Sparta.
Two of his students were involved in violent rebellions against Athens.
While the students died, Socrates was still around to blame.
The Athenians were worried.
He'd poisoned more young minds with his anti-democratic ideas.
So he was put on trial and sentenced to drink hemlock.
When your 10th grade history teacher brought up Socrates,
it was probably to show how far we've come from.
This kind of censorship poisoning,
an old guy for saying stuff is wrong today in America,
we don't punish people for bad mouthing the government that's protected by the
first amendment. We can even burn our flag, except well, that was a lie.
And not for the reasons you think basically for as long as the first amendment
has existed. America has been incredibly eager to bypass it. Indeed.
Our so-called inalienable, right?
Because like,
if there were a book with covers made it you'd think that's intriguing.
I wonder what's in this book that they saw fit to give it covers made of pure.
And then you open it and.
All being decided in the Supreme court as late as the 1970s.
But what is censorship? Anyway, broadly speaking is the suppression of words,
images or ideas that are offensive, harmful, or otherwise objectionable to well,
whoever the sensor happens to be in the case of Socrates,
the governments of Athens censored him because they believed he was a threat to
their democracy and its most obvious form the sensors or the people in power
openly trying to stop certain ideas from reaching the public.
And that might mean creating laws that let you poison old guys or banning and
burning books, outlawing religions.
Nobody expects the.
Spanish inquisition or even straight up controlling the press.
It's the kind of censorship America's founders feared when they created the
first amendment prohibiting the government specifically from limiting speech or
establishing a state religion, sociologists Sue Curry, Janssen calls,
such limitations, regulative censorship, regulative. Censorship is hella old.
Like when Egyptian Pharaoh are not incent Royal officials to physically chisel
away any references to gods on tombs, temples,
and walls that weren't his preferred God and Chinese emperor chin show Wong
ordered the destruction of books so that people would believe the world began
with his reign centuries. Later in Europe,
the Catholic church published its first index of forbidden books.
And then there was the Spanish inquisition,
which not only prohibited certain books, but expelled Jews from Spain's borders,
torturing and killing thousands of people in the process.
This is the kind of censorship,
our history books love to talk about which isn't a bad thing.
It's just not the only thing over time.
The kinds of things that got censored and the way they got censored started to
change with censorship came more opposition to censorship.
More people started defending freedom of expression and freedom of the press
globally.
And those ideas became particularly popular in Europe and its colonies.
Sweden became the first country to formally censorship of the law guaranteeing
freedom of the press in 1766, after it finally became a country,
America cemented the freedom of the press and expression in its very first
constitutional amendment. Hell you censorship. Oh, um,
fudge censorship just seven years later,
founding father bill of rights champion.
And America's second president John Adams signed first of the sedition acts,
which, uh, would drag you to court for criticizing the government. Oh boy,
just like the ancient Athenians feared Socrates Adams and his fellow Federalists
were concerned that their political opponents were going to spread
anti-government ideas. As a result of 25, people were arrested,
mostly editors of newspapers who criticized the Adams administration.
One guy was arrested for referring to the press as the blind bald crippled,
toothless querulous Adams.
The clear abuse of the law caused protests across the country.
And it was repealed a few years later under Jefferson's presidency,
but there would be much more successful attempts at censorship by the
government. So we see this open push for censorship and the ensuing backlash,
which on does it. So if you're looking to label some ideas as unspeakable,
what do you do? You roll out licenses or classic Dettori bodies,
for example, it's not that you can't say whatever you want on a TV station,
but you do need a license to run a TV station.
Janet.
And well to maintain that license,
you need to follow the rules laid out by the FCC,
which means not saying certain words.
Yeah.
Without getting a hefty fine on the classification front,
you can make whatever movie you want, but if it has too many bad words,
the NPA will give it an R rating and movie theaters. Won't let the kids see it.
Sue Curry Jansen describes this method as the good lie,
which serves to hide the operations of the sensor more often than not people who
aren't specifically persecuted by the censoring bodies,
hop on the bandwagon and accept these new forms of censorship because such rules
fit with their worldview.
The licensing kind of censorship is how Woodrow Wilson pulled off.
One of the most far reaching censorship drives in American history during world
war one, he formed the committee on public information,
both a creator of propaganda and a licensing authority.
It manipulated and censored all external news coverage about the war on a scale,
never seen before in the U S eventually they had control over every part of the
media.
They reviewed every newspaper and every radio program to make sure it didn't
impede the war effort. But instead of the framing of everything is banned.
The framing was the nice authorities are going to look everything over and
approve it. First, the good lie,
150,000 Americans emboldened to bolster the war effort,
signed up to volunteer for the CPI.
They did that stuff for free Wilson also passed the 1918 sedition act,
making it punishable by 20 years in jail to utter print,
write or publish any disloyal, profane, scurrilous,
or abusive language about the form of the government of the United States.
Basically a series of laws ensured that if you printed anything,
the CPI didn't approve of you were in big trouble.
A guy named Charles Schenck was sentenced to six months in prison for
distributing a leaflet,
opposing the draft with the headline long live the constitution of the United
States like Socrates teaching, it was dangerous.
It might jeopardize America's national security.
Now you might've heard the phrase shouting fire in a crowded theater to describe
reasonable limits on free speech.
If I create a fake panic during a play where people get trampled to death,
no one would say that's within your constitutionally protected rights.
It's censorship in a way, but he censorship.
Most reasonable people would support.
But the common sense of the phrase is hugely deceptive.
It became a go-to example of acceptable censorship after it was lifted from the
text, the Supreme court decision for one Mr. Shank and his antidromic leaflets.
But despite the obviousness of his logic,
it was meant as a metaphor for why shank must be censored.
The court unanimously upheld his conviction,
criticizing America's involvement in a war was now akin to making a false panic
at the theater Wilson contended that censorship was absolutely necessary to
public safety and like the Supreme court people bought it. Ironically,
it was Wilson censorship drive that suppressed news of a dangerous new form of
influenza that was decimating American military basis.
While this censorship was meant to bolster morale for the war effort,
nearly half of troop fatalities were a result of the censor disease.
It was this censorship which led to the name, the Spanish flu,
since Spain's press freely reported on this for boating topic.
And this wasn't some weird aberration in American history,
four time presidential candidate,
Eugene Debs was also thrown in jail for criticizing the war and the shank case
wasn't overturned until 1969. As late as 1971,
the Supreme court had to decide if wearing a buck,
the draft jacket in a courthouse was protected speech.
While this might seem like bill of rights, one Oh one,
it was up for debate among the nation's foremost legal authorities.
If the naughty word and the phrase was worthy of constitutional protection,
a protection, the court affirmed in a five, four decision. Thank God, Hey,
no bleeps because it's history kids,
but not all censorship comes from written laws or court decisions.
A lot of it comes from us often on a wedding as the result of government
interference. According to Jansen, this is constituent of censorship.
Other scholars call it sociological censorship or existential centers. Sure.
But it's basically the set of unwritten rules and norms that shape and limit the
ideas people have,
the censorship that system allow tolerate or even ask for under Wilson,
many papers, actively censored influenza news,
just to do their part in the war effort,
censoring bad things about the war effort just became a norm held by people even
with out the threat of fines or imprisonment and its effects continue.
And you'd long after the war was over.
Constituent of censorship happens without government's interference too.
For instance, I might not want to show at the house of former wisecrack CEO,
Jacob Solomon, to leave him a note that says,
I am the lizard King for fear of personal or professional repercussions and
served.
They have 300 journalists by the Columbia journalism review about one quarter
responded that they purposely avoided newsworthy stories, citing reasons,
ranging from fear of embarrassment or potential career damage to protect in
business interests.
People also center themselves with deference to the sensibilities of others.
Like not saying curse words around your not screaming,
vaccines are safe and effective in a whole foods. Parking lot,
all the pointing fingers about people feeling censored at work places or
universities. This is often what's happening.
Groups of people hold certain values and running a foul of those values could
lead to a range of reactions from I respect you less to,
I'm going to openly criticize you with my peers for deviating too.
I'm going to try to get you fired in our history of censorship.
Janssen writes that constituent of censorships are elastic limits or permission
can be expanded or contracted,
but constituent censorships can never be fully eliminated.
What she means is the rules and norms that define what society finds acceptable
are flexible and can change.
Sometimes the government can influence them and sometimes the public can
influence them, but they're always there.
People often scream censorship about things that are kind of inevitable due to
this,
the same people who think they're being censored out of fear of their peers will
say mean things about them might very well be the same people,
making a 40 minute rage filled response video for the crime of suggesting the
last Jedi wasn't that bad with no sense of irony.
What they might really be complaining about though is the Overton window.
You can imagine the Overton window as a range that slides up and down on an
ideological spectrum within the window are a range of ideas that seem diverse
summer popular insensible to one side of the spectrum and the others are popular
and sensible to those on the other side of the spectrum.
But out of view are ideas that are radical even unthinkable until
they aren't.
According to the free market advocate think tank guy who coined the term,
Joseph Lehman, the window shifts and moves.
What was once unthinkable like say an interracial kiss on television in the
1960s might become radical than acceptable and eventually even
commonplace the window of both moves and widens through exposure to new ideas.
Because if you force people to consider an unthinkable idea,
even if they don't like it all the less extreme ideas suddenly seem possible,
maybe even acceptable.
But remember there are always things outside the window,
things that beyond public tolerance,
when people are you about cancel culture and censorship and response to public
figures, receiving a torrent of criticism,
it's often really a complaint about where the Overton window is.
Even for the loudest people, shouting free speech on the internet.
They probably draw the line like most people at say endorsing pedophilia
and oftentimes people as a group expressing their feelings that such and such
person has bad ideas does dumb is itself.
Just people expressing their own opinions.
Should we censor those people from criticizing.
Know there's this video?
It gives me this video gives me hope and certain moments where I'm like,
this is actually a pretty good video. And then it gives me brain cancer.
At the same time, probably not.
The point is cries of censorship directed at one side are often a smoke screen
for saying my constituent of censorship is normal and fine.
Yours is not case in points.
University professors getting fired for their ideas while the narrative is that
the censorious left is getting anyone fired,
who doesn't fall in line with their ideas.
Independent reviews actually show that while yes, this does happen.
It happens in far greater numbers to left-leaning professors at the hands of
conservative backlash. But back to the Overton window,
there's a bit of confusion over how it moves a lot of popular thinking,
claims that it's all on corrupt lawmakers who use their power to intentionally
shift the window to the extreme,
whether it's to be inflammatory or make one's fringe ideas more acceptable and
promote their own aims in a Politico interview.
Lehman are used that this is a misconception.
While you can push the window by advocating for radical ideas.
He says it actually happens through public discourse. He says,
this idea that lawmakers are trying to shift the window is absolutely false.
Lawmakers are actually in the business of detecting where the window is and then
moving to be in accordance with it.
Others like Noam Chomsky argue that some lawmakers have an interest in keeping
the Overton window where it is,
and that they'll do a whole lot to make sure people are ignorant of what's
outside of it. In 1998, before the Overton window was a mainstream idea,
Chomsky argued the smart way to keep people passive and obedient is to strictly
limit the spectrum of acceptable opinion,
but allow very lively debate within that spectrum even encouraged the more
critical and dissident views that gives people the sense that there's free
thinking, going through a lot of channels, but especially the media.
We hear a lot about what kind of ideas are radical or crazy that runs through in
elaborate filter of corporate interests.
Others have called this kind of censorship markets, censorship,
basically that while we're giving the illusion of choice,
the people who run the news organizations, publishers, and so on,
get to decide what is allowed.
So while people might be upset when Spotify employees are trying to fire Joe
Rogan, it's the same kind of editorial.
Decision-making the company employees every day,
like when they decide to reject my pitch for the bring back potatoes and taco
bell podcast, or the Spotify should pay musicians,
more podcast brought to you by Spotify.
It's not that these decisions don't have the effect of shutting out ideas,
but it happens on a daily basis that people are otherwise fine with every time a
museum ops to show one artist, instead of another,
every time someone does or doesn't get a book deal.
Every time a news anchors contract is renewed or not.
I'm not saying this kind of market censorship is good, but in less,
the argument is Spotify should pay everyone with an idea with no regard to the
content of that idea. Our concept of censorship is a little lacking here.
Otherwise it seems like people are saying,
my idea should get past this filter others should.
And while well-reasoned people generally concerned about the way misinformation
spreads on social media like wildfire,
we might not want to be so enthusiastic about Twitter,
removing articles about Hunter Biden while coordinated disinformation might be a
huge threat to the very idea of free and open discourse.
It doesn't take a lot of that connecting to see how our methods for fighting
those things can end up haunting us.
It might just end up seeding power to people in Capitol Hill or Silicon Valley
to decide what ideas are too dangerous.
It's the same rationale that got shanked thrown in jail under Wilson and the
blacklisted actors for their political affiliations during the McCarthy era and
the 1940s and fifties,
the federal government thought they had a solution to a similar problem.
The FCC mandated that TV and radio stations give airtime to both sides of any
controversial issue. It was called the fairness doctrine,
but something happened in the early 1960s. John F.
Kennedy figured out he could gain the doctrine by appointing political allies to
the FCC, and then lean on them to find ways to manipulate news coverage.
He told his buddies to rigorously enforce the fairness doctrine and they
enforced it to be fair to Kennedy by using their FCC powers to call it any
unbalanced criticisms of him,
Nixon would later do the same thing using the fairness doctrine to pressure TV
networks, to give more fair and balanced coverage of the Vietnam war.
What he really meant was more flattering coverage and censorship of the Ward's
atrocities. Okay. But what does all of this have to do with big daddy,
Twitter hiding tweets and YouTube demonetizing videos? Well,
a lot of people are worried that the same thing that JFK did to the TV networks
could happen with the internet.
If the FCC is in the pocket of whoever's in charge,
they might abuse their power and influence the media.
We consume attempting to worst internet platforms into widely skewing content
moderation, to what governments want seems maybe bad.
And also just like another kind of censorship ironically pushes by conservative
politicians to be fair to right-wing news.
Let's ended up with Facebook systematically favoring right-wing news while
suppressing left-wing news,
Facebook as to the central problem with a lot of censorship discourse.
So much of the history of censorship relates to the government and the
distribution of the press and public spaces.
Problem is public space has virtually disappeared in the last century in lieu of
public squares and meeting places.
We have shopping malls and privately owned internet companies.
And like the taco bell that threw me private companies are in no way obligated
to honor free speech laws. But fact is the same.
It's just that instead of the government regulating speech companies do
censorship today happen in a myriad of ways,
but our narrow focus can often obscure the greater systems at play.
It's easy to get mad when a professor loses their job,
it's harder to look at everyone who never got a job offer and why it's easy to
get mad at Twitter.
It's harder to look around and figure out what kind of public venues for free
speech still exist and why they've almost all disappeared.
And while some may propose a free market of ideas to Duke it out,
the free market has always been a fiction.
Ideas are filtered through so many levels of market and constituent of
censorship before they can even get written in a book or put on the news while
we should be on the lookout for the Socrates drinking hemlock version of
censorship. It's just a small part of the picture.
It's an incredibly complicated problem with no easy solutions.
And for everyone who's saying it is maybe take what they say with a grain of
salt I'll end with scholar,
Michael Holquist who writes that censorship is impossible to escape and that the
institutions are legislation promising free speech are band-aid solutions.
He says to be for or against censorship as such is to assume a freedom.
No one has censorship is one can only discriminate among its
more and less repressive effects.
So what do you think is censorship inevitable or should my lifetime ban at taco
bell be immediately lifted big thanks to our patrons for all your support
murder, that subscribe button, like you're an Athenian condemning Socrates,
and don't forget to ring that bell and as always, thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].